we are starting today with what are
effectively in a sense counter sanctions
sanctions issued not only sanctions but
also bans from the country of russia
issued by the kremlin against the number
of american officials up to and
including joe biden now there's not very
much
that's funny
about what's going on with the russian
invasion of ukraine there's there's just
very little that's funny in all of this
but
the sanctions and banning biden from
russia it's a little bit funny i will
tell you there's a newsweek piece about
this russia sanctions joe
and hunter biden which i just find
hilarious hillary clinton
and 10 others president joe biden his
son hunter biden hillary clinton and 10
other officials have been sanctioned by
russia in response to the sweeping
sanctions imposed by washington the
russian government announced today
yesterday rather the sanctions barred
the officials from entering russia
russia's foreign ministry said in a
statement translated to english that the
measures were on the basis of
reciprocity now here
it's actually beneficial that the people
that are sanctioned don't need to go to
russia
and don't have bank accounts in russia
and don't have assets in russia and it
makes it all pretty weak now you'll
remember that russian oligarchs
organizations and entities have been
targeted by u.s europe and canada in
response to the ukrainian uh invasion by
russia russian president putin himself
has been directly sanctioned
the translated russian foreign ministry
statement tuesday said the reciprocal
sanctions were the inevitable
consequence of the extremely russophobic
russophobic
course taken by the administration
others sanctioned by russia
secretary of state anthony blinken
defense secretary lloyd austin chairman
of the joint chiefs mark milley
cia director william joseph burns white
house press secretary jen saki even gen
saki
and a bunch of other people now jensaki
was asked about this yesterday and she
basically made the obvious points about
it um take a listen to this
sanctions sure we're imposed today by
russia against yourself
president biden and other top u.s
officials
do you have a response to that and how
will it impact any of you if at all sure
i would first note that president biden
is a junior so they may have sanctioned
his dad may he rest in peace can you
imagine i mean this is one of those
things where you know
in the united states
i love what gen saki is saying because
it's almost too on the nose and also
irrelevant if you understand how russia
works let me explain what i mean by that
on the one hand
in the u.s
if you sanction you know joseph biden
rather than joseph biden jr
you've not sanctioned the correct person
it doesn't matter what what your intent
was in some places there's other places
where intent does matter but it's sort
of like a legal question but we have the
general belief in the us we're like
that's a legit technicality where like
if you don't say that it's junior
it probably applies to someone other
than the person it's supposed to apply
to and jen saki's right about that
but the other thing you have to
understand is in russia it they don't
care about technicalities like that
if the intention was to sanction joe
biden the president of the united states
the fact that joe biden is biden's dad
deceased father they don't those are not
the types of technicalities that courts
in russia care about
unless it's to their advantage in which
case all sorts of technicalities you
couldn't even imagine will matter
there's a bunch of interesting books
that that talk about this including bill
browder's book i believe it's called red
notice he's been a guest on the show
even if you don't like bill browder or
you don't find him trustworthy his
explanation of how
the the justice system is a very
amorphous thing in russia are are quite
quite interesting uh let's get a little
more here from gensake
the second piece i would say is that
won't surprise any of you uh that none
of us are planning uh tourist trips to
russia none of us have bank accounts
that we won't be able to access so we
will forge ahead yeah at this point i
don't think anybody is really looking to
go to russia from american leadership
it's interesting that hillary's on the
list
but no trump sanction no trump ban
also notable and interesting
and of course
this is serious fuel for the conspiracy
theorists the conspiracy theorists are
hearing this
and uh they are
coming up with all sorts of different
hypotheses about why this is the list
and why is hillary on the list that
that's that's a really really big deal
uh to them
um anything else of interest here
um
oh this is notable at the same time
russia does not refuse to maintain
official relations if they meet our
national interests so they're making it
clear that even though these people are
are banned and not allowed in russia
if there were
some particular reason why they would
want to meet with people or maintain a
diplomatic relation they will do that of
course that that makes perfect sense not
a big surprise
imagine
if they included
hunter biden's laptop on the list that
would be pretty fascinating that would
be pretty fascinating
um sadly
another american journalist has been
killed by russian troops this time maybe
journalist isn't the right word a member
of the media a camera person
and it is getting
very dangerous in ukraine to be a member
of the media mediaite reporting
fox news cameraman killed
an attack that wounded benjamin hall
um earlier in the week we talked about
the injury to benjamin hall
we now are learning about
um the death
of uh cameraman pierre zakrusky who was
killed outside kiev in ukraine uh fox
news media ceo suzanne scott announced
the tragic news in a note to colleagues
she said zakrewsky 55 years old and hall
were reporting in the village of orenka
when their vehicle was struck by
incoming fire
ukrainian officials say alexandre
kufschenova the producer working with
the fox news team was also killed in the
attack
the notice says dear colleagues it was
great with a great sadness and a heavy
heart that we share the news this
morning regarding our beloved cameraman
pierre zakrewski he was killed in orenka
outside of keeve ukraine was with
benjamin hall yesterday news gathering
when their vehicle was struck by
incoming fire um the hill also reporting
on this
fox cameraman killed a mid attack in
ukraine this article um mentions a
little bit more about zakrusky and uh
the degree
to which this is crossing party lines
and you know i think there's a lot of
people may not realize
um
in media very often the camera people
cameraman camera women
um around the world
sometimes they're freelance contractors
i mean they may technically be employees
or they may be freelance contractors or
whatever the case may be but the point
is they very often don't subscribe to
the same political views as the media
outlet which they are covering and the
uh understanding is i mean listen
regardless this would be a tragedy and
attacks on on members of the media are
deplorable and and absolutely sickening
and disgusting
but some people reacted by saying well
here's a here's a right winger who got
killed not that it would make it any
less bad um very often these are
sometimes they're union and
internationally sometimes they're
freelance and that that's just that's
just neither here nor there i think an
important point to mention is that in
general
it's dangerous to be a journalist
journalist
not necessarily a camera person um when
russia doesn't like what you're doing
and as dangerous as it has become on a
statistical basis in ukraine so far
we've now had multiple deaths and a
number of members of the media injured
you can also look up the wikipedia
article list of journalists killed in
russia
and they actually have a table that goes
by year
and um
the numbers are quite high they're in
the hundreds in the hundreds for
journalists killed
um
in russia it is not good
uh here is cnn correspondent scott
mclean
uh cnn remember sort of paying tribute
to uh pierre zakruski i should also
point out that we learned that a long
time photojournalist pierre zakrewski
for fox news
his body was found he's been killed in
keith
yeah that's right the second
foreign journalist to be killed pierre
was working for fox news we understand
the correspondent as well
is in critical condition according to
fox
i actually had opportunity to meet
pierre two years ago when i was in kiev
i can tell you he was extremely popular
in the industry it's pretty small
industry especially on the road with
international journalists everybody
seemed to know him
i don't usually drink a lot when i'm on
the road because we're busy but i can
tell you on our last night
i have a picture with him and we were
three sheets to the wind because he was
just a lovely guy to hang out with and
we were just having a riot hanging out
with the fox guys i ended up running
into him in 2020 a few months later when
we were in the lockdown in london where
he was living and
i just remember he was really
trying to get out the door trying to he
was bored sitting around in london
during the lockdown and so i know that
he really loved his job he really loved
the travel he really loved the adventure
obviously this is a tragedy and uh it
seems like he's universally loved in
this industry and i can tell you from my
brief experience with him he was just a
really lovely guy to be around so
there's the personal tragedy someone
died here someone with a family has died
there's also the reality that yes war
journalism
is not without its dangers there's no
question about it but
uh it's it's a small sample this has
been a short engagement so far this
invasion of ukraine by russia uh and and
we've you know the the number of people
killed is thankfully low in terms of the
raw number
but on a proportions basis for how many
journalists are there and how long it's
been
russia is not taking particular care not
taking particular care
when it comes to members of the media
and it is getting
dangerous enough and keeve that a
36-hour curfew has been announced
after residential buildings were hit by
heavy shelling so
all part of the tragedy the invasion is
a tragedy the civilians killed a tragedy
members of the media killed it's it's
it's bad uh members you know peop
ukrainian citizens just defending their
country
uh kill it's all absolutely horrifying
and by the way
i would say it's also a tragedy when
russian soldiers are sent without a clue
sometimes as to what's really even going
on
and very often
not even wanting or believing that this
is a worthy cause when they are killed i
mean a lot of them are kids as well
so it's all tragedy uh let me know what
you think you can find me on twitter at
deepakman we have a packed program for
you today
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
the david pakman show is a viewer
listener audience community supported
program we have a membership program
which you can sign up for at
joinpacman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members we also provide a
commercial free audio and video feed of
every single show
every day for our members and it's made
available six hours before
the shows are made public you can sign
up at joinpackman.com
very easy to do
uh takes just moments and remember alex
jones hates the bonus show oh the bonus
show where you want to make money
everybody else that makes money to find
themselves is bad hard to imagine a
better endorsement of the bonus show
than the fact that alex jones is
infuriated by it all right this is
almost beyond belief
there is video of a meeting at which the
trump riots were planned you
i mean
lordy there are tapes
these are not exactly criminal geniuses
that's for sure look at this politico
reporting
the doj has announced a film crew
was present at the january 5th meeting
between leaders of the proud boys and
the oath keepers
the details provide new evidence of the
encounter between the two groups whose
leaders played a key role
in the breach of the capital the
following day
they're not sending their best and
brightest brightest
prosecutors say a documentary film crew
was present
when proud boys leader enrique tario and
oath keepers leader stewart rhodes met
for 30 minutes in an underground parking
garage on january 5th now remember
they've both since been arrested and
charged the details revealed in a
justice department court filing on
monday provide new evidence of the
encounter between the two groups whose
leaders played a key role in the breach
of the capital the following day
quote while in the parking garage tario
told another individual he had cleared
all of the messages on his phone before
he was arrested prosecutors wrote in a
filing urging a federal magistrate judge
to detain tario pending trial
tario further stated no one would be
able to get into his phone because there
were quote two steps to get into it
sounds like two-step authentication
prosecutors say after tario left dc that
night part of a court ordered that he
stay away from the city while facing
charges related to his conduct during a
december 2020 rally he traveled to
baltimore
that evening tario used the phones of
associates to make a number of calls and
to log back into his encrypted messaging
accounts after regaining access to his
accounts tario assured his men his phone
had not been compromised reuters first
reported on the existence of that
meeting and the fbi's interest in it
last month
new details suggest tario played a more
direct role than previously understood
he's been charged stewart rhodes has
been charged etc
uh reuters report ex-proud boys chairman
tario ordered detained pending trial in
capital riot case this is also from
yesterday
a u.s magistrate judge in miami tuesday
ordered tario the proud boys chairman
former to be detained while he awaits
trial on charges stemming from the riots
so that is what we call pre-trial
detention now i've spoken out before
about the problems with pre-trial
detention in the united states it's
often applied unfairly it's often
applied um uh in practice it ends up
affecting those who don't have money for
private lawyers we've been talking about
this for a very very long time these
right-wingers only now care about
pre-trial detention i've been talking
about it 10 years on the show they
didn't care they didn't think there was
any problem now they think there is but
there are videos
of the meeting between tario and rhodes
the people
in the videos have been running around
for a year
and many of them probably thought they
were in the clear
but it appears as though what the feds
are and have been doing
is following it all up the food chain
it's now hit stuart rhodes
it has hit enrique tario who knows the
full scope of what's in in these videos
but there is a very good chance that
there are still very very serious
charges coming for additional people um
and i mean consider
you know when this all happened back in
january of 2021
there was maybe the idea among some that
this was all going to be figured out
quickly
some people might be charged and some
might end up going to jail prison etc
uh but we are now
14 months in and the charges are still
coming and not even everybody who's
going to be charged has been charged so
the upside is we're now at hundreds it
might get to thousands of people who
suffer some consequences for their role
in the riot that would be a very good
thing
on the other hand
i am still
completely not optimistic
that
really the big insiders because remember
the real reason that this even got going
was the false belief that the election
had been stolen from job from donald
trump by joe biden who promulgated that
it was a bunch of republicans and donald
trump and mark meadows and uh so on and
so forth are they going to be held
accountable no i still don't think that
the vast majority of them will be
that's a problem but
if people committed crimes they should
be charged and they should have the book
thrown at them and uh that does appear
to be what's happening video video of
the meeting unbelievable
uh we have been covering a number of the
different conspiracy theories
speculations
and reactions to different aspects of
what's been happening in ukraine this
includes the so-called bio weapons labs
bio labs we've talked about it ad
nauseum so far today i'm going to scale
up the crazy a little bit for you
lara logan
is a now a fox nation host i don't
remember her full credentials at one
point i believe she was involved with 60
minutes and um
a lot of different things have happened
with lara logan but she does appear to
have gone completely off the deep end
cuckoo for coco puffs and her latest
claims this this is just completely
outrageous
she
said that
first of all she does soft anti-semitic
propaganda
repeats russian propaganda and also
starts to take a sort of supernatural
occult demonic perspective
on what is happening you have to see
this to believe it let's just jump into
the first clip and by the way this is
all happening on real america's voice so
even the venue in which the conversation
is happening is whacked uh take a listen
something is very wrong with lara logan
what troubles me about the moment that
we're in is that we have such a
selective and a narrow reading of
history you know president zielinski may
be jewish but he's not the only one in
this who suffered during the second
world war whose ancestors suffered right
i mean look at putin how many relatives
did he lose in the siege of saint
petersburg so so right off the bat
zielinski may be jewish there may be a
history of anti-semitism
but other people have also suffered like
putin oh okay all right go on people
don't know their history they don't know
what made vladimir putin and i'm not a
defend you know i'm not defending him i
don't need to defend vladimir putin well
these are sort of the soft apologia that
we've seen of putin and it's also not
that heavily veiled
anti-semitic stuff of stuff as well i
mean what what is zelensky's jewish butt
i mean what what is she even talking
about and then it really goes off the
rails if you think this is wacky just
wait my job as a journalist is to try to
understand what is the truth here i
don't like being lied to and we're being
lied to on an epic scale when we're told
your only choice is you have to be a
hundred percent with zelinski who's a
puppet who you can find on the internet
in black stilettos and leather pants you
know with shirtless doing a spoof
dancing with the stars kind of
entertainment video that's a mock of a
ukrainian group that does this kind of
satanic occult type of music video so
now she's raising that zelensky's been
involved in satanic occult stuff
that's completely outrageous the guy was
a comedian
okay now you could say well a comedian
shouldn't be president or you might say
a failed businessman shouldn't be
president sure we can have that
conversation
uh but what on earth is she talking
about what on earth is she talking about
and i mean zelinski was selected like so
many of our leaders and honestly with
with big tech and with election fraud
these days we don't know how many
leaders all around the world have been
selected for us now that's another one
of these um russell's teapot sort of we
talked about russell's teapot yesterday
she
doesn't actually have any evidence
that zelensky won
due to election fraud
or due to big tech she doesn't have any
evidence if she had it i guess she would
present it although i don't know maybe
she doesn't even care about evidence i'm
not sure
but it's accepted by ed henry and the
host oh yeah yeah yeah yeah and it puts
everybody else in the position of having
to disprove that zolensky one due to
it's the same thing that they do here
actually voted in but what we do know is
that there are increasing problems with
technology and the digitization of our
world because we look at what's
happening with covert okay oh actually
what has happened globally we are
fighting the same battles all over the
world to pretend that this war is about
russia and ukraine is a it's just a
bare-faced land so there's a lot of
really important things here one of the
themes these people all have the same
themes right one of the themes is you're
not being told the truth and
you it may not even be possible to know
the truth because there's so many people
trying to lie to you and all these
different things and it's sort of hard
hard to know that number two
making situations that are about
something appear to be far more
complicated than they are now is this
when you think about
the history and fall of the ussr
vladimir putin's personal history the
history of ukraine
um the history of nato the history of
you
there there's a lot there and there's a
lot of history to know
but all of these it's too complicated to
even understand it type analyses
are designed to softly make people
question
whether russia was wrong to invade
ukraine um and let's go to the uh we'll
go to one more clip here um and here i
mean
this is i cannot emphasize how bonkers
this interview is i mean this is on
throughout the ukrainian military you
can see that black son of the occult on
their uh body armor even on the female
soldiers who are paraded in front of the
world as being you know such an example
of ukraine's um independence and spirit
and nobility it's all satanic and it's
all the occult
it's all crazy i mean it's it's half a
step before saying there are ukrainian
witches and we've got to burn them and
they are wearing the black son of the
occult
i mean this is on
yeah
so completely off the rails lara logan
and i i
mean listen every time i talk about her
if i if i don't mention this people
email me and say i'm wrong to mention it
i'm sorry if i don't if i don't mention
it people say i'm wrong not to mention
it
but when i mention it people say that
doesn't really matter she's out of her
mind
lara logan was assaulted i believe it
was when she was covering the uh
revolution in egypt
that's terrible
she may be suffering ptsd she may and
any anything may be going on
her
perspective on covid has been whacked i
mean just whacked
and now this kind of like
veiled anti-semitism
putin apologia
there's satanic occult stuff going on
this is wacky wacky stuff
and to whatever degree this has to do
with what she experienced i don't know
but i'll put it all out there we'll have
these clips on our instagram which you
can find at david pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com david pakman
show today we're going to be speaking
with justin guest who's an associate
professor of policy and government at
george mason university and also author
of several books including the
forthcoming book majority minority out
next tuesday a really great having you
on i appreciate your time
thanks dave it's great to be with you
so um when we kind of study and talk
about reactionary thinking and ideology
which is often fear-based it's hard not
to stumble across fear being generated
with this idea that people different
than you are going to take over and
become the majority in your area country
region whatever and that's going to be
bad and that'll be dangerous and you
know some sometimes tucker carlson
sometimes says uh dirtier and poorer
will be the outcome of that so uh this
idea of minority majority groups and the
changing demographics has been used for
a very long time to achieve political
goals can you talk a little bit
generally to get us into this about the
different types of reactions that
societies have when we see the racial or
ethnic balances shift
sure it's a great question david you
know it depends on whether we're talking
about this at the individual level or at
the societal level and at the societal
level we know precious little about how
big societies governments respond to
great demographic change and that's
really what motivated this book majority
minority now at the individual level
there is actually extensive research
what happens when we alert people or
simulate great demographic change and
the findings are pretty consistent
people are territorial they're defensive
uh they're fearful they're insecure and
most of it is driven by uncertainty
by the uncertainty of what will life be
like under these uh scenarios
and
uncertainty
generally comes with
the fear that it might not be so good
right i mean uncertainty in in a taken
in a sort of
uh literal way could just mean we don't
know but oftentimes uncertainty is
associated with well that that sounds
like it could be bad
well it takes a special type of human i
think to sort of embrace uncertainty
yeah generally you know human reactions
to uncertainty are going to be fearful
uh because of the insecurities
associated with it uh you fear what you
don't know um you know there are some
people who seize the future who sees the
prospects of uncertainty but yes
generally the you know fear is is one of
the primary emotions if not just anxiety
or discomfort are there societies that
have been able to kind of embrace
demographic shifts that are significant
without significant conflict
so embrace is a strong word
i think that's actually a standard that
i don't think we even need to
necessarily meet um i think what we
really are looking for are societies
that can can foster and
cultivate a culture of coexistence um
you know and so my work is really
concerned about whether societies pivot
towards conflict or towards coexistence
because there's always going to be some
degree of backlash some degree of
discomfort and i find that it to be
universal in all the different societies
that i study that have already undergone
a majority minority transition and by
that i mean where the majority ethnic or
religious group loses its numerical
advantage to one or more minority groups
and in those situations you can always
expect some degree of conflict some
degree of anxiety but the question is
whether societies are resilient and can
redefine who they are in order to evolve
with the changing composition of their
people so can you give us some examples
of where it's gone on the better side
and on the not so good
sure sure so i studied six countries six
societies really carefully uh in this
book uh and uh two societies uh really
pivoted towards suppression of
minorities um the most overt kind of
suppression takes place in the middle
east region and i study bahrain a small
island off the coast of the arabian
peninsula where you effectively have a
sort of second-class system for
immigrants
but also a second-class system for
people of a different religious sect
than that of the ruling uh
uh royal court and party um
alternatively you can look at singapore
which is another society that is
characterized by suppression but in a
far more subtle way
singapore is concerned with evolving
into a greater sort of civic identity
but in its policy making and the way it
governs it actually reinforces ethnic
divisions between its people
now if you take a look at some american
examples so hawaii which many people
obviously associate as america's 50th
state um hawaii was previously an
independent kingdom and when it was an
independent kingdom before it was
forcibly annexed by the united states in
1893 hawaii was actually a very
multi-ethnic and majority minority
monarchy and in that society hawaii
actually embraced many of these
newcomers and actually facilitated uh
intermarriage among them now that's not
to say there wasn't some nationalism
there wasn't some backlash there was
but there was a sort of greater
understanding of what it means to be a
native hawaiian
that it could be something that was
shared and bestowed upon someone that
really took on new meaning in the 20th
century after americans took over the
the archipelago because the americans
put in a very strong assimilationist
regime that basically treated any person
of color any person who was not white
anglo-american as uh as someone to be
dominated in a sense and so what you saw
was a lot of intermingling among
hawaiians with people who were
previously thought of as immigrants the
japanese the chinese the filipinos and
that intermixing
created a reconception of what it means
to be hawaiian in the future
that's interesting and there you know
it's it's very popular among some in the
united states to say
hawaii is just a mess and they give
different reason reasons why
uh but um
not often cited
is this i mean it's it's interesting you
would think because hawaii tip is a blue
state typically votes for democrats you
would think that the right might have
wanted to seize on multiculturalism is
the reason why hawaii is a mess
economically or whatever it is that
that's often stated but maybe it's not
even necessarily that well-known a story
in the united states i don't know
yeah i don't think of hawaii as a mess
at all i think of it actually as a
paragon in many ways um you know the way
that they have been able to embrace
demographic change over the course of
their history to broaden the
understanding of what it means to be uh
kanaka you know to be a native hawaiian
um is really actually exemplary for how
i think we want to evolve the civic
identity of what it means to be american
um very generally speaking top level
there's the idea that in the united
states the way the political divisions
are
the left tends to be more accepting of
demographic changes while the right
tends to be more
fearful and critical of demographic
changes can you flesh that out a little
bit more in terms of whether that
general assessment is always or mostly
correct and maybe some of the exceptions
or kind of strange interplays to this
perspective
sure it wasn't always true particularly
when the left was associated with
unionism um which in historically
speaking you know we're talking 80 to
100 years ago um was actually relatively
close and kind of reproduced a lot of
the social uh
um and cultural inequities in american
history um but certainly in the
contemporary moment that's true um
generally speaking the left not only
embraces uh demographic change it almost
anticipates it um you know with the
election of barack obama many democrats
crowed about uh demography being destiny
and how this was the path to electoral
victory forever after um and certainly
republicans have not just um you know i
i think you know fear uh demographic
change but they've actually leaned into
that fear and allowed it to consume much
of its politics until now um in many
ways the republican party is very
nostalgic party right now uh yearning
for for an earlier period in american
history that when they could make
america great again um and so you know
in light of that demographic you know
the relationship with demographics i
think that is generally the case but
it's also been reinforced by our
politics um ever since the democratic
party really moved to the center
economically and embraced kind of
greater neoliberalism the real
differences between the the democratic
party and the republican party in the
united states are principally on
cultural um issues right now right i
mean certainly there are economic
differences but the real you know gaps
are on cultural matters and a lot of
that is about how you treat uh minority
groups whether they're uh minorities uh
because of their sexuality because of
their ethnicity because their religion
um whatever it is you know generally
speaking that is where you see the
greatest kind of um
rift
yeah it seems even things like wanting
uh a citizenship question on the census
or the focus on critical race theory to
the extent that any of the people
focusing on it understand what it is
these these things seem to be not so
indirectly related to exactly these same
issues we're talking about
oh i i think you're being modest uh they
are directly related okay good politics
of demographic change absolutely um you
know one of the uh greatest dividers um
but also uniters uh in the in in the
course of history uh of great
demographic change and majority minority
transitions is the socialization of
youth you know how we actually
educate our young people uh going
forward and are schools the the sort of
engines of
of uh integration and upward mobility
together are you integrating your
schools and are you learning a common
language and moving forward together or
are you going to have debates over what
we teach in schools uh and many ways you
know textbooks have have actually have a
long history of being debated whether
they recognize the contributions of
minorities over history uh how you treat
um historic inequities and perhaps the
inconvenient truths of of the country's
history um is quite common and then you
know with regard to census questioning
that's a matter of power uh when you are
excluding you know people from a
population count um you're also
excluding them from power and so these
questions are integral and they're
produced by the fraught politics of
demographic change can you give some
other examples of the the sort of uh
battles that are being had so we've got
the citizenship question critical race
theory you've talked about textbooks and
how history is uh taught there's let's
make english officially the one official
language of the united states what are
some of the other kind of uh uh ways in
which we can see this battle thought
sure you can see it in the battles over
culture
over music and over art and over sports
i think back to khan kaepernick's
effective cancellation from the nfl
when he was taking a knee before the
national anthem in protest of police
brutality and discrimination i think of
the battles over confederate monuments
and the desire to protect them right um
you can also look at the world of
commerce you know do we see racialized
poverty or do we see the the marketplace
as a as a place of interdependency um
the politics of affirmative action in in
whether it's uh education or employment
um all of these are very much related to
demographic change and how we manage it
so there's the question there's sort of
empirical questions about is the
demographic change happening and what
data points do we have as you've
researched in the book about
other places that it's happened that's
one side of it there's also the reality
that for a lot of people
this rhetoric really resonates and some
at least of donald trump's rise to power
was you know mexico's not sending its
best
china's treating us very unfairly
etc you know muslim terrorists are
coming up through the u.s mexico border
uh ms-13 is being quote released into
the community all of this different
stuff
it seems very politically effective and
i'm curious your thoughts on
how can it be diffused so that it's not
so politically effective or is there
something visceral about it that just
works
sure there is something visceral but it
can be defeated and you know politicians
and public officials more broadly uh
including even business leaders and
civil society leaders have to become
more adept at calling out fear mongering
for what it does it divides and if we're
going to survive as a nation if we are
in and this is the most nationalist
thing i think i can say uh is you want
to survive as a nation and if you want
to survive as a nation you have to
cultivate some degree of solidarity and
unity and when you have you know
politicians trying to profit in the
short run to win elections uh on with
divisive rhetoric uh that doesn't have a
huge evidentiary basis um we're all
gonna lose and so i think that you know
the opponents of this kind of
fear-mongering have to call those things
out the you know people like donald
trump are trying to divide american
society which weakens us uh in the
future it weakens us economically it
weakens us socially and so i do think
that that's the way forward but
complementing that idea is you can't
just tear down the opposite side tactics
you also have to have a strategic vision
yourself and that's where the creativity
comes in we have to actually cultivate
an understanding of who we are as a
country in one in a way that evolves
from the historic understanding of a
white mainstream uh it has to be one
that is not necessarily hit to race or
ethnicity or religion but one that is
about a civic sense of belonging a civic
sense of purpose yeah i mean it's tough
i i guess
we would benefit from having sort of
like a uh some kind of a pr consultant
help with this conversation but you know
when they say
um
immigrants commit more crime and they're
taking our jobs and so on i mean it's
very it's easy in a sense to say
that stuff's not true and here we have
all the studies and native born
americans commit crime at a higher rate
and why wouldn't they they don't have a
fear that they're committing crime in a
different country you know we can do all
that stuff but it just seems like you're
kind of you know pushing a boulder up a
mountain in a sense because it's just
it's always tougher to to interject
facts when the emotions work so well
sure well look we have to invalidate
these falsehoods you know when they're
being made we can't let them stand
because uh they shouldn't stand you know
they're completely false and
in some cases they're just exaggerations
in other cases they're absolutely false
but that's a negative strategy you have
to have an affirmative strategy too
right
and you know whether it's a pr agency or
just some visionary right um have to
work as a country i think as a people
with a million leaders not just one uh
who is thinking clearly and
strategically about what holds us
together as a country what holds us
together as a nation and what's the best
argument is is it basically this country
is built on
people
from all over coming here and
contributing what they have to
contribute
and we almost all of us are here for
that reason and it's it's it it is i
mean i don't even know i'm kind of
thinking out loud here about what is
that positive vision
sure well let me give you some fodder
and you know we can keep we can keep the
conversation going offline you know and
all of you can continue to think about
this in the shower and you know tomorrow
morning um there's some there's some
enormous advantages that the united
states has in reconceiving who we are
you know first off we are a country
where everyone has some kind of
immigrant story even native americans
these days are heavily intermarried with
people of immigrant origin and so almost
every single american is touched somehow
by a journey to this country and that is
something that is
remarkably unifying
secondly we have a really high rate of
intermarriage and mixed ethnic ethnicity
mixed religion children um being born
right now in fact actually the rate of
mixed-race people has grown by 300
percent that's threefold over just the
last 10 years which is blurring the
boundaries between people that can
otherwise be used to divide us
and so we also have a very strong civic
idea of what it is to be an american and
so these are all advantages i think in
in crafting that new american story that
other places simply don't have
that rich history and heritage of
immigration that continues into the
future and so in many ways america is
not one static thing and it's you know
it's it's a fool's errand to try to
create something monolithic it's just
not who we are we're an evolving place
we're an idea we're a country that is
constantly in motion always under
construction and i think that our common
story really comes through in our common
struggle and the idea that everyone
wants to dream yeah the the the reality
that race and ethnicity are also just on
a very practical level increasingly
blurry due to what you're talking about
that that's an interesting uh factor as
well the book is out next week march
22nd the book is majority minority we've
been speaking with the author justin
guest who's also a professor at george
mason university really appreciate your
time today justin thank you anytime
david thank you
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick talk
you know on this show sometimes we'll
look at the wacky and zany and kooky
things that right wingers say and we'll
laugh and we'll say oh it's so silly and
it's so dumb but
we don't necessarily
always
worry for the future
of humanity
and the united states
and our legislative bodies on the basis
of you know every random thing that
marjorie taylor green or whoever
necessarily says
i have an example today of something for
you
that does make me really worried about
the future of american democracy quite
frankly um because of the level of
ignorance that it shows
combined with a sort of brazen
confidence despite that ignorance
and the reality
that this may be someone who is going to
be one of only 100 senators in the
united states
herschel walker is a trump-endorsed
republican senate candidate running in
the state of georgia and herschel walker
recently asked you know
if there's evolution if evolution is
real and we humans homo sapiens
evolved from apes
why
are there still apes on the planet if
the apes evolved to become humans
why are there still apes
we're going to look at the video in a
moment
there are more than 331
million people in the united states
only 100 at a time get to be members of
one of the most powerful legislative
bodies in the country the united states
senate one of those 100 might be someone
who questions
the truth of evolution
because there are still monkeys
on planet earth let's take a look at the
clip this is this is genuinely
depressing it really brings me it's i i
have fear and despair because of this i
have no
pleasure this is not fun
here that means somebody up there had to
say let there be light that the earth
started and then he had to put someone
there on earth remember adam was there
remember adam came there then eve came
so somebody had to start it out so that
means it had to be a god because they
didn't just some bomb blew up and
started out and then i tell you
something now
we're gonna get to the really crazy part
this idea that listen
if there was some first human here's the
first human because you start this that
this is not new stuff we're treading on
very worn ground here the idea that you
sometimes hear from creationists is well
okay listen
i came from a human mother
and my mother came from a human mother
and my grandmother came from a human
mother and so if you just follow that at
some point there was the first human
mother
and therefore that person must have been
created like that by a god or higher
power and of course when you understand
the slow process of evolution
and you understand how that works
you realize that the premise is wrong
it's logical to think
if ad infinitum
it was my mom and her mom and her mom
and her mom and her and it was just all
modern humans right you might end up
saying well i mean somebody must have
designed and created that first human
but we understand that that's not the
case so this alone we could spend an
hour on but let's get to the really
wacky part that's getting a lot of
attention as i heard i think about this
because at one time science said man
came from apes it's not at one time but
by the way but yeah okay
did it not
i've read that's when you go to it every
time i read or hear that i think to
myself you just didn't read the same
bible i did well this was interesting
though
if that is true
why are there still apes
think about it you know now you're
getting too smart no no no no thing
about this we have an evolution that is
we've gotten so intelligent that if that
is true why are there still apes and
then the conception of a baby
let me tell you science can't do that
they still trying to do it but it can't
because there had to be a god
so when god came
okay
now this is not actually a crazy
question i mean you go you know you go
to third or fourth grade
when
i think that's when kids start being
taught about evolution
there are lots of curious
uh naive wide-eyed bushy-tailed eight
and nine-year-olds who would say hey but
if we came from apes why are there still
apes didn't the apes become human and of
course there's an answer humans did not
evolve from a modern living ape like a
modern chimpanzee
we evolved and descended from a common
ancestor of apes we share
a common ancestor that's the best
science we have right now which lived
and died
in the distant past and that means we're
related to other apes
and we and those other apes came from an
earlier
ape of some kind
now
that's an eight or nine-year-old that
would ask that
imagine if herschel walker becomes a
senator i mean really think think you
know we have 331 million people in this
country to pick from some of them are
kids so we're not literally okay but
we've got hundreds of millions of people
to choose from
how do we solve really serious problems
in this country inequality
poverty education
hunger
uh climate change
when we have a hunt it's just a hundred
people in the senate and at least one of
them may there might be others in the
senate who believe the same stuff but
when one of your hundred is a senator
saying if evolution is real why are
there still apes on planet earth
how do we solve problems if that's the
case
we can't
and so when we wonder man why
politics is so log jammed and we just
we're not getting anywhere and it's
these you know
trivial arguments about stupid stuff and
people getting fined for not wearing
masks and people who think the vaccines
modify your d how
we have 331 million people
the senate has 100 members representing
those people
and a guy who's saying if we if
evolution is real why are there still
monkeys on earth
has a genuine shot at becoming one of
those hundred and is endorsed by former
president donald trump
it doesn't bode well
it doesn't bode well and it is not funny
it stopped being funny a while ago
the republican national committee
is now
joining
donald trump and others
in desperately trying to keep their own
email records away from the january 6
committee investigating the trump riots
of 2021 once again this is not the
behavior of parties who have nothing to
hide cnn report rnc tries to stop 2020
email communications data from going to
the january 6th committee on wednesday
the house select committee investigating
the attack on the u.s capitol is poised
to receive data from the republican
party's email communications platform
salesforce and the republican national
committee rushed to court last night to
try to block it
the development is the latest to emerge
about the house's aggressive pursuits
reconstructing political misinformation
after the 2020 election that contributed
to trump supporters storming the capital
on january 6th
the rnc alleges that the house
subpoenaed a sales force seeking
information about election
communications including those related
to former president trump quote would
give the select committee unprecedented
access to the rnc's internal political
strategies and to private personal
information regarding supporters
practically adding reasons that their
emails should be investigated what were
they telling their big donors
right on the eve
of the january 6th trump riots political
strategies which they want to hide are
exactly what got these people where they
are now political strategies that
involve lying about election results
intimidation calling for violence
spreading fear and propaganda through
right-wing media trying to invalidate
voters purge voter rolls change vote
totals send alternate bogus slates of
electors all of those things are why
we're in this mess
and so the january 6th committee is 100
percent right to say hey maybe they were
talking about that stuff in their email
communications and if there isn't
illegal stuff in there they don't really
have anything to worry about i mean
everybody knows what the strategies are
you think we're going to learn about new
strategies by looking at their emails we
know what the strategies are what we
might learn is that they were openly
plotting and communicating about them
with donors and other higher-ups
the article goes on last week the rnc
filed a lawsuit against the house
committee
complaining about the sales force
salesforce subpoena's breath
but that lawsuit was unlikely to succeed
as it was aimed only at the committee
not at salesforce and there is no
emergency mechanism to fast track it in
court so salesforce was planning to turn
these records over
but now the rnc has added sales force to
the lawsuit will they uh ultimately get
those records i don't know we'll find
out you know very soon but think of the
irony and think of the hypocrisy and the
double standard
the dnc emails were hacked you might
remember that
and uh putin told trump very strongly
that it wasn't russia and trump believed
him okay whatever but the dnc emails
were hacked
and of course republicans didn't take
the high road they didn't they didn't
say these were incorrectly released
we're not going to use them they
immediately use those emails for
propaganda and here they are saying well
no no no no no it would be completely
improper we're not talking about hacking
we're but they're acting as though
this legal mechanism
is worse than the hacking you're like no
no no it would be inappropriate to use
that legal mechanism to get these
documents from us and the documents
shouldn't shouldn't be released that
would be wrong
but when documents were hacked they were
fine to use them and publicize them etc
etc and this is to be fair to be fair
both sides do this not to the same
degree but both sides when there are
documents that are
made public
if you don't like the content of the
documents you focus on the impropriety
of them being made public
if you like the content of the documents
you just focus on the content democrats
and republicans they all do this but
they're not as hypocritical to this
degree if they did nothing wrong they
should have nothing to hide and it's
more than that they should want to clear
themselves of any wrongdoing
even if their strategy gets out to the
committee they should be eager to prove
we were not involved in anything
untoward or potentially against the law
now what do i think is potentially going
to be exposed by these documents if they
are released on today's bonus show we're
going to talk about what's going on with
supreme court justice clarence thomas's
wife ginny thomas jenny thomas we now
have learned attended
one of the january sixth events she
attended the uh january 6 rally before
the attack she wasn't at the attack but
she was at the rally before the attack
and clarence thomas thomas has recently
been making statements about we don't
want the supreme court to become
political i am
suspicious
that part of what is now the kind of
next ring in these concentric circles
around the trump riots is something that
relates to ginny thomas and thus has the
potential to pull in clarence thomas and
we're going to talk about that a lot
more uh on today's bonus show they've
gotten away with a lot of shenanigans
for a very long time
and uh the the january 6 committee is
right to go after these email
communications and let's hope that they
get them
we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to davidp
here's kind of a funny tongue-in-cheek
voicemail
but it's also very accurate take a
listen to this
hey david uh i think it's about time
that we start calling these right-wing
nuts what they really are
communist sympathizers right
now
it's sort of tongue-in-cheek but at the
same time you know russia is not at this
point what we would call a communist
country by by most definitions although
there are people who would still say its
guiding principles are still those same
communist principles of the ussr but the
point is a good one which is the right
spends decades at this point building
building building the story
that the american left just kind of like
basic democrats are socialists marxists
and or communists
but
it is actually the right
that through donald trump being enamored
with these right-wing authoritarian
dictatorial authoritarians has ended up
being the bigger supporters of those
with communist leanings for lack of a
better term
good luck explaining the double standard
to them we've got a great bonus show for
you today the senate has approved a bill
to make daylight saving time permanent
do we like this and will it actually
happen we'll discuss
idaho is now copying the texas
anti-abortion law
and this is exactly what we expected
and they're doing it we will talk about
that and yes ginny thomas the wife of
supreme court justice clarence thomas
was at the january sixth rally that
preceded the january sixth trump riots
we will talk about what we know and we
will talk about how this may end up
connecting to the current january 6th
committee investigation of those trump
riots all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money everybody
else that makes money to find themselves
is bad very dangerous bonus show if you
believe alex jones i consider it an
absolute delight sign up at
joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access and i will
speak to you then
you